[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lundi 11 heures du matin monsieur segura
chauffeur de la voiture plasma du
département de la drôme est appelée sur
la nationale 7 à plus d'un kilomètre au
nord de la palud au lieu dit les blache
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame mikaelian coiffe les olives près
de marseille atteinte de multiples
fractures agonise tandis que son fils -
touché s'agite à ses côtés fou de
douleur et d'impuissance
[Musique]
on évacue malades mikaelian elle mourra
son arrivée à l'hôpital d'orange
alors que l'on transporte les victimes
dix au total occupants trois voitures
dans les hôpitaux de la région
l'embouteillage atteint de part et
d'autre du point d'impact plusieurs
kilomètres
la vie reprend lentement la stupéfaction
laisse la place à la curiosité à la
chasse aux souvenirs
au milieu de cette incroyable confusion
un homme seul andré lefeuvre charcutier
à sotteville-lès-rouen sortie à peu près
indemne de la collision est demeuré sur
place on peut partir en vacances
voyez vous
mais vous n'aviez pas un endroit précis
une destination précise
alors maintenant
j'en sais rien
merci tu oublies de rien n'en sais rien
je n'ai aucune idée
comment ça s'est passé exactement
racontez moi je suivais que je vois
recours puisque j'ai rien vu que la
bagnole qui tombé devant moi et c'est
tout il j'ai rentré dedans automatique
j'ai rien vu autrement je suivais la
file normalement
la voiture a tombé devant moi et puis ça
a été fini vous étiez sur la droite vous
moi j'étais bien sur ma droite derrière
je suivais une voiture une voiture elle
est tombée entre moi et une autre
voiture je peux pas vous dire si elle a
eu quelque chose ou qu'ils ok je n'en
sais rien
votre famille ne pas n'est pas trop
gravement atteinte
on enlève les restes des plus voyants de
ce qui ne fut qu'un drame assez banal
tombe fois répété on laisse le soin au
soleil et au vent d'effacer les autres
cicatrices et l'on dégage le terrain
pour que s'affrontent à nouveau dans un
éternel paris avec la mort c'est
inconscience motorisés
comment ça va
très père
voici c'est votre premier accident le
oui et vous partiez chaque année on le
pensait mais toutes les arts tous les
ans depuis toujours oui vous savez qu'on
va en parler à votre accident
vous avez bien bien tiré oh oui moi j'ai
rien juste des égratignures au principe
toute personne mariée dans votre vie
d'avant que c'est un petit peu choqué
c'est normal parce qu'avec un shack
pareil vous avez vu arriver oui puis
j'ai surtout voulu moments passés à
travers le pare-brise mon père pour la
portière ils ont été éjectés
[Musique]
forte de ses 18 membres la famille de
francis john tallarico enfants et grands
parents compris arrive tout droit de new
york pour dévaliser la réserve istream
de la cafétéria de l'autoroute et
redécouvrir les machines à changer la
monnaie
[Musique]
la puissance de consommation de ces
américains est absolument incroyable
sandwich eskimos coca cola café tout y
passe et tout s'y passe apparemment sans
problème et sans imagination puisqu'ils
ont encore la force de se photographier
sur un fond d'autoroute en tout point
semblable au freeway new york washington
la famille de francis john tallarico
n'est pas au bout de ses peines il y
encore trois cafétéria qui regorge de
glace et de café avant leur prochaine
étape où les attendent des cuisses de
grenouilles et des escargots de
bourgogne toutes choses légères s'il en
fût
[Musique]
retour sur la nationale nous sommes loin
de ces italo-américain boulimique et
crise les risées ici la cabane et de
bois la voiture une pièce de musée et le
personnage semble tiré d'un roman de
zola
vous êtes bien là dans le fond vous êtes
comme des amoureux tous les deux
oui
ça vous a pris du temps
ça et les sous
ne préfériez pas être sur la côte d'azur
[Musique]
ici on sera mangé par genou ça irait
très bien
vous habitez en temps normal bien vu
arriver et vous y travailler là bas
moi j'ai travaillé 16 ans et j'adore ma
chatte saucisson
connaissez pas c'est si bien sûr et puis
ça fait vingt trois ans qu'elle a bon
ils sont un peu fous ces gens qui
descendent sur la côte d'azur là comme
des
faux que ça plaise
moi je préfère ici
ça nous plaît
pour les vacances les vacances le
week-end tous les 15 jours mme y en a à
tous les quinze jours de l'été oui
olivier on est bien par lui et en plus
le mois quoi on peut
si on a dit ça va mieux je
veux pas déranger ici d'enfants mais
tranquille
et après tu as fait d'accord
week-end samedi pour l'autoroute qui
emballe on a nous a déjà deux mondial
l'aspect
de prix augmenter comment on entend
demander à l'étude pour nous c'est pas
pour
l'ap hp pour vendre mais pas trop près
de la route
[Musique]
aubervilliers c'est pire que sa
belle-fille et ben alors c'est sans
arrêt bourgi
est ce que la
vente mais ici ce qui se passe des
choses quand on habite comme vous au
bord de la nationale pour trouve non pas
tellement parce que les gens surtout pas
ces puits ne s'arrête jamais c'est rare
il s'arrête une ou deux heures mais j'ai
pas envie de les accompagner par moments
ça oui
je voudrais pouvoir
vous avez envie de vous en dire et
mademoiselle
moment des départs en vacances on va
tous les genres la rva tout sur les
voitures sont aux fenêtres là ils sont
vraiment joyeux en fond d'écran signe
d'amitié on a bien envie de partir avec
eux c'est sûr mais c'est pas toujours
facile quand on sait qu'on y va aussi en
vacances et le moindre regret mais quand
on part pas en vacances comme ça m'est
arrivé l'année dernière devait pas
partir en vacances je voyais tout le
monde s'en aller vendola gros sur le
coeur à les voir partir
après le départ passé c'est fini on n'y
pense plus enfin
franchement qu'on y avoir de l'emprise
de regret que les autres parce qu'on les
voit partir en vacances alors que ce
qu'ils font quand même dans l'intérieur
voyez moi les voitures passent et ils y
pensent peut-être moi on est obligé d'y
penser
il y a ceux qui font la nationale en
voiture ceux qui la font en autocar mais
aussi ceux qui la font à bicyclette ils
sont rares ce sont les seules que nous
ayons rencontrée
et
je n'ai pas peur des poids lourds quand
vous êtes sur les nationales si un peu
c'est surtout gênant on les prend
rarement voilà on l'a prévenu julien
houle et nationales
nationale on l'a pris aujourd'hui parce
qu'il n'ya pas de y'a pas d'autres
chemins puis c'est mon avis peu à côté
quoi je suis
enfin sinon avec des possibles on sort
de la salle on prend des petites routes
même les très petites routes oui non
mais tout petit groupe qui perd
d'ailleurs puisque vous allez enlever tu
vas on sait pas encore on espère
descendre dans le midi
on a rendez-vous à avec un camarade
avignon 15
j'espère y être c'est assez hypothétique
ouais c'est une aventure dans le fond de
descendre comme ça en vélo ont une
aventure a pas beaucoup de risques et ma
télé pourquoi vous descendez en vélo
c'est pour des raisons d'économie
un peu où il peut et même surtout aussi
parce que ces sportifs
samedi rien de plus sportif et de plus
périlleux que de tenter de se glisser en
venant d'une départementale dans le flot
ininterrompu de voitures qui descend la
nationale en cette fin de semaine
que les travaux soient en cours travaux
un faisable l'hiver à cause du gel et
c'est l'extraordinaire embouteillages
sur plusieurs kilomètres les bohémiens
c'est ainsi que l'on appelle dans les
villages les ouvriers qui refont la
route préfère avoir la protection de la
gendarmerie car ils se font incendié par
les conducteur irascible
il arrive même parfois que des bagarres
éclatent
mais combien de temps vous travaillez
sur cette route
on y travaille à
deux mois oui
et ça fait qu'on est temps que vous
faites ce métier aux moyens va attendre
attend maintenant que vous travaillez
constamment sur les nationales ouais on
leur file national il était porte
montage enfin tout petit face à vous
attriste pas de voir tous ces gens qui
partent en vacances pendant tout le
travail et on voit ça nous donnerait un
petit peu la flamme enfin
comment vous est venu à ce travail
[Musique]
j'ai commencé j'étais dans la
boulangerie avant et puis
la farine mais parfois je me suis
embauché dans les travaux publics ça m'a
plu à la farine me convenait pas là vous
est pris dans le goudron et vous êtes
pieds dans le goudron bas je me porte
mieux oui oui pourquoi pas te dire que
j'étais dans la fine je peux de 54 kg
puis je tombé dans les pommes à tout
bout de champ on m'a dit qu'il fallait
prendre le grand air
et l'odeur du goudron ça vous gêne pas
au printemps il se dit habitué dont
vous êtes mariés non célibataires
célibataire il faut être célibataire
parce que on est constamment en
déplacement
mais y'a pas les gens qui sont mariés
puis keith qu'ils déplacent avec leur
famille dans des caravanes dans des
caravanes mais avec les enfants de
porter loin
bref pour l'école c'est un pose des
problèmes way elle n'ait pas envie de
vous marier
s'y méprend et que je trouvais lots
situation que ça passe aussi pour
continuer dans ce métier en étant marié
quel âge vous avait 42 ans il faudrait
vous dépêcher quand même maintenant sept
ans
c'est vrai dans le conte drôle de vie
oui mais l'avantagé qu'on avait c'est
plus qu'assez jusqu'à cette année ci
avec progrès des heures on pourra gagner
alors on gagné largement nuit maintenant
ça devient dur avec les mets comme les
autres on est limité au point de vue
horaire autrement avant lamellaire
pouvait se permettre
la vie humble parce qu'on avait dit vous
avez des bonnes petites feuilles quoi on
tend des heures beaucoup ont cédé 14 15
heures par jour aux éditions ses
croyances
pour y est habitué
on sait pas
ces points un tout jeune qui peut y
faire
tout de suite parce que il tient pas
tant l matin ils oublient de se lever
tout à côté des travaux et tout au bord
de la nationale un paysan et son ouvrier
travaille dans un champ ces deux mondes
pourtant géographiquement si proches ne
se rejoignent jamais sauf lorsqu'une
voiture culbute dans le champ ce qui est
quand même assez rare
les automobilistes ne le voit pas et lui
a fini par ne plus voir les automobiles
travaillent à la mer non et oui les
autres partis en vacances on touche à
tout et rien ne sommes pas jaloux
ça vous fatiguent pas un petit peu par
même davantage de travailler alors que
tous les
jours au bord de la nationale a marqué
14 des films et de la peau d'un
programme
on ne passera comme les ouvriers des
jeunes à la cloche une autre côté vous
prenait jamais de vacances oh non
pourquoi euros parce que avec les bêtes
en tapant avec les bases ces pratiques
n'ont pas possible
c'est pas une vie un peu dur
oui n'auriez pas envie formellement de
faire autre chose pour pouvoir partir
non vous avez des enfants mais qu'est ce
qu'ils font et val jeune fille à paris
et ce qu'elle fait là bas
on est dans les délais dans des bureaux
j'ai affichettes avec moi mais qui
travaille aussi la campagne allait
mais pas envoyer du spam à faire
d'autres études pour essayer de faire un
autre métier que j'étais à dire qu' il
n'avait pas tellement de facilité pour
la grandeur
alors vous l'avez regardé avec vous pour
l'exploitation oui je voulais qu'il ait
fallu qu'elle
est ce que vous êtes déjà descendu soit
le désir
n'est pas envie d'y aller en voyant
toutes ces voitures qui l'est semble du
tout n'avait jamais vu la lenteur la
montagne sinon j'y suis allée comme shad
tajan temps mais surtout à quel endroit
du final
mais du tout à la joie de partir en
vacances les touristes pique nique le
long de la route il s'allonge afin de
mieux inspiré cet oxygène indispensable
les gaz de voiture
[Musique]
arrivé il ya combien de temps quelques
temps a tout de suite approche des
jeunes mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
sans ballon pour vous la nationale c'est
un peu la route des accidents la route
des morts fais pas ça les deux côtés
quoi vous avez l'impression d'être
plutôt mécanicien de francfort alors les
obligés de faire les deux bassets pour
la mécanique ou la fin on avait obligés
c'est tragique finalement sur cette
route des vacances les gens rentrent
vite sont tellement pressés de rentrer
au soleil ils sont obligés de prendre
trop de risques
le but comme étant faites vous ce métier
bah ça fait 15 ans je suis installé là
ça km et quand vous avez attaqué vous
pensiez aucun autre verset travaillent
pas autant je pensais faire davantage de
l'été lé plus chaud et sur leurs plus
enfin que les roulements de la vie soit
chaud si c'était à refaire vous pourriez
même métier
au début c'est très dur maintenant
exprès ou bien êtes habituellement
offerts aux habitudes on s'habitue même
à cela
dimanche le flot de voitures ne
s'interrompt pas plus nous descendons
vers le sud plus il grossit et malgré la
trêve dominicale les routiers sont
toujours au travail
ça tourne
pour histoire
quoi
c'est pas pratique et bocsa alors je
charles de gaulle
zapatero page
au
final
pour les routiers c'est une véritable
ruche le patron monsieur segura un
ancien chauffeur a épousé la fille de la
maison
maintenant votre
travail et ça fait un petit peu dérangé
pareil durement les fermes et manger il
faut que le relais messieurs se doit une
part
de 80 de parts fatigué d'entendre
comment toutes ces voitures entend
d'habitude je crois
et
si on est un peu comme les gardes
barrières
ah oui vraiment vivace en dehors anglais
sous le vent sur la nationale et on dort
quand des spots dormir quelqu'un qui
n'est pas d'habitude par américaine et
quand vous partez en vacances est-ce que
vous pouvez dormir si vous êtes au calme
c'est les premiers jours lorsque vous
travaillez que ça va être difficile à
reprendre la rue team
r27 est ce que vous voulez mais
il a fait notre vie quoi
très accroché
est ce que vous pourriez vivre ailleurs
ont certainement sur tellement bien peu
mieux reviendrai quand même
mon mari ça lui aurait fait la peine de
quitter le quai croupier qui n'avait pas
conclu d'entente y envoyer ça il fallait
qu'il a travaillé en usine certainement
plus il veut plus alors que la cannelle
su finir
par moments ça me dérange pas on est
pendus reprendre le volant le match
comme on dit
un petit peu mais enfin
vu ce qui arrive maintenant sur les
routes sur 3 en moyenne
après avoir quitté l'autoroute à la
sortie de montélimar nous guettons sur
la nationale 7 le restaurant de monsieur
barnier nous avons une mission précise à
remplir lui transmettre les amitiés
d'une famille de rapatriés d'algérie que
lui même et ses parents ont accueilli en
1962 lors des événements est ce que vous
l'avez cette nationale sed
nécessairement
certains c'est un accès international
qui nous permet de vivre il faut le
reconnaître humblement alors on est
obligé de l'aimer ou alors d'un accord
sur le plan alors ensuite personnel
c'est ennuyeux tant mieux parce que
normalement de bruit énormément de
circulation en été entendons nous bien
des difficultés difficulté circulation
des difficultés de départ de l'arrivée
que ces tirs a il faut faire des tas de
cirque et des tas de petites ficelles
les acrobaties lacour bah si on prend
l'habitude c'est certain mais enfin des
acrobaties ça paye un jour où la fosse
ont quand même s'en rendre compte on
risque tout instant on risque un
accrochage sans que ce soit sérieux
accrochage c'est toujours ennuyeux
chaque fois que vous parti faire vos
courses dans le fond c'est un peu
l'aventuré
laventure non quand même pas quand même
pas mal enfin
il faut être entendu il faut faire
attention et comment faites-vous pour
croiser cette file ininterrompue de
voitures et bien ma foi
voyez on attend patiemment qu'il y ait
un taux de circulation et a sombré
filtre dans la circulation de traverse
assez rapidement parce qu'il ne faut pas
ayant victorieusement franchi le cap de
cette nouvelle épreuve qu'il répète
plusieurs fois par jour monsieur bernier
fait ses courses
le plus dur reste à faire retourner chez
lui
qu'est ce que vous faites là il est cuit
vous regrettez le polar qu'on a
complètement à gauche
et ta soeur
c'est vraiment la seule formule pour
vous pour andré chez vous oui c'est une
une des formules louis la manière ne pas
être bloqués le plus longtemps possible
voilà ce à quoi si vous faites vous vous
arrêtez carrément à droite alors là il a
plus moyen de passer oui c'est vraiment
laventure qu'en voiture c'est l'habitude
c'est l'habitude pour ça que tout à
l'heure je vous disais on prend des
risques
me des risques calculés quand même
nous sommes maintenant vraiment dans le
midi tout prend une couleur tout a une
odeur introuvables ailleurs
la moindre charrette de paysans
transformé par ce rêve qui pousse les
gens à se précipiter vers la côte d'azur
à braver mille morts pour un peu de
soleil de cigales et de mère a des
allures de diligence ou de carence royal
mail aurait fait partie de la provence
tout concourt ici à respecter la règle
du jeu un peu plus loin ce sont les
cavaliers qui laissant au galop la
nationale il aurait été anormal que nous
les rencontrions pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous faites sur la
nationale 7 nous montons dans le var à
cheval on compte passer une semaine
avant
[Musique]
et vous êtes parti de quel endroit nous
sommes partis de marseille hier matin
vous habitez aux habitants et vous fait
ça à chacune de vos vacances
principaux williams possible toutes les
années et tous les dimanches tous les
week-ends nous partons à cheval nous
faisons les routes a aujourd'hui n'y ait
pas ce qu'on peut pas avoir des amis
dans le var le rendez vous ce soir il
n'y sera pas est-ce que vous met dans le
civil après dans les villes qui ont été
aux travaux en italie
je suis miroitier de marine
non célibataires
parce que si vous étiez marié vous voyez
comme ça partira cheval comme de carbone
alors certains non je crois que c'est
possible qu'elle connaît pas malgré sa
mort on a pas mal d'amis sa voie et sa
voix seule où il s'en va mais c'est leur
fameux vient de rejoindre soir parce
qu'on fait des haltes reçoit où nous
portent les vivres où on ne porte pas de
trucs et souvent les femmes en arrivent
même peine qu'en bêta basque un homme
peu moins de la liberté alors il vaut
mieux rester célibataire sur nos
pratiques
les cigales ont repris le dessus il n'y
a plus qu elle le mistral et les chevaux
dans une ultime contre attaque déchirant
le silence accordé le présent pour se
faire entendre précipitent les voitures
au fossé
[Rires]
vous savez vous devez mettre le moteur
en route
[Rires]
la manière marche
gérard
doucement
[Musique]
à ce point du voyage les voitures sont
les tapis volants guidé par une main
invisible sur un route de coton rien ne
peut plus les arrêter imbriquées les
unes dans les autres additionnez
confondues dans une sorte de gigantesque
serpent de mer elle flotte en direction
de cet immense horizon anglais où elles
vont sabine et
[Musique]